Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
No using SCPs to create tentacle monsters
- even if Dr. Palmer asks nicely!
There are a vast number of anomalous
technologies that would allow a bored
Dr. Bright to try his hand at playing god
with some genetic engineering - Including,
in theory, creating tentacle monsters.
This may seem innocent enough, but due
to certain Japanese censorship laws,
tentacle monsters have taken
on a whole new meaning.
Especially to one of Dr. Bright’s colleagues,
Dr. Palmer, who’ll happily tell you about
her favorite anime: “My Husband is a
Tentacle Monster In Another World.”
Needless to say, the Foundation would prefer that
their employees do this kind of thing at home.